welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars Ahsoka episode 3 time to fly Balin
skull saw a few per goal in the Clouds
of sea toss in episode 2 and sure enough
they are back to really apologize
we're sorry for taking
friend oh please don't click away no
more whale speak in this video I promise
let's break down this episode scene by
scene for all the Star Wars Easter eggs
and details you missed okay we see the
same opening metallic faces and helmets
as last week Vader 3PO clone trooper
helmet HK assassin Droid The Inquisitor
mirak huyang Stormtrooper Chopper and
sabine's helmet so quick note on Baroque
before we begin I did not address this
before because I think it's a very silly
Theory but no I do not think morocc is
Ezra Bridger are you kidding me Ezra
would have had to come back from this
other Galaxy and regardless of his Dark
Side Temptations our man would never
have broke bad and become a freaking
Inquisitor come on if we learned nothing
from Rebels by the way if you haven't
seen all of rebels and don't have time
to watch all those episodes or you just
want a refresher we made an excellent
four-part Rebels recap series to catch
you all up on all of the episodes the
characters Easter eggs and the bits of
lore that you need to know please watch
those and share those with all the
others out there who are like I don't
know how to get into this series now
when it comes to Moro we did see Sam
whitworth's name in the additional
voices of the credits of episodes one
and two leading someone to believe that
morocc could be Starkiller but morocc's
performance has been done by stunt actor
Paul Darnell we also saw his name in the
credits of episode 2 and Sam Whitworth
is just one of these regular lucasfilm
dudes who voices one-off characters like
that short trooper and Andor he could
have voiced any of those droids or
helmeted figures like notice how his
name also appears besides names like
Matthew Wood the sound editor who has
voiced General Grievous and Ben Fortuna
so who knows we may just get a number of
voices that echo through the past in a
future episode and a sound team blanket
credited all the voice actors who helped
out on the season but in this episode
morocc actually speaks
on the way nothing
now I gotta admit the voice does sound a
bit like Sam whitwor to me but Sam is
also just a very good voice actor whose
voice is just kind of like the taste of
chicken everything sounds like it but
the most important detail is that in the
credits of this episode the role of
morocc is fully credited to Paul Darnell
which is a big upgrade from him just
being credited for stunts last week now
whitworth's name does once again appear
at the very end of the credits with the
additional voices section just as it
disappeared in episode one and two so I
just don't know if they would have
credited morocc entirely to Paul Darnell
if Whit were had been voicing him like
they bumped up Darnell's Credit in an
episode in which the character speaks
it's a big deal episode credits are
contractually required to be accurate
and I know some of you may say well
there was an episode of Rebel season 4
episode 11 where Dave filoni credited
the loath wolf Doom to the force but
folks that was animation in live action
episode credits were taken very
seriously so all of this is really to
say I don't know we're three out of
eight episodes in and I think morocc is
just gonna be morocc okay the episode
opens with ahsoka's T6 and hyperspace
when we saw hyperspace looking like this
in the Mandalorian season 3 episode 1
grogu saw pergol floating past them and
yes this is a very big pergol episode
huyang trains with Sabine using a Bakken
which is a Japanese wooden sword used
for training in kinjutsu who Yang says
these are foreign positions they are
numbered similar to the mandoa numbers
that the armorer shouted at Din jar and
while training him with a darksaber in
the book of event chapter five
and of course we are reminded of Sabine
training with the darksaber with Ezra
and Kanan and rebel season 3 episode 15
Trials of the darksaber one two three
four
five six these were the basics
originally taught to Sabine by Ezra in
that episode and Sabine made a bit of
progress with the darksaber it's
starting to feel lighter in our hands
but she later handed off to bogoton at
the beginning of Rebel season 4. so
other than that period And whatever
Ahsoka taught her in the in between
years Sabine is still very much a novice
here huyang the Jedi orders architect
Droid an expert on lightsabers uses
these four Hollow Sabers looking a bit
like General Grievous for dogging it
like that but these are to record the
vector and the accuracy of sabine's
swings light yellow for more accurate
orange fur off Target and more skew
angles Ahsoka proposes how about Satoshi
this is a reference to zatuichi the
blind swordsman the recurring character
in 25 Japanese Samurai films from 1960
Institute in 1973 George Lucas cited the
Hidden Fortress in the seventh Samurai
as Inspirations for Star Wars this
technique involves Sabine wearing this
blindfold mask similar to the ones worn
by padawans in the Jedi Temple that we
saw in Attack of the Clones and the
makeshift one that Obi-Wan had Luke wear
on the Falcon in A New Hope but this
mask is an interesting symbol on it kind
of reminds me of something that they
might have had in the Jedi Temple
training room that we saw in flashbacks
and Rebels season 2 episode 18 shroud of
darkness when the future Grand
Inquisitor wore masks but those had eye
holes in it a similar mask that Kane and
Jairus put on after he was blinded in
the season 2 finale of rebels and that
malachor Sith Temple thrawn did keep one
of these Jedi Temple masks on his desk
in season three and four this blindfold
mask might also be based on the Kendo
mask which is used in Japanese swords
martial arts but I just find it
interesting that Ahsoka keeps this whole
training set on her ship with lightsaber
training instruments recovered or
rebuilt with huiang to keep this art
form alive even if she's uninterested in
the Jedi Order like she may have rigged
her table in seats to descend to the
floor to give her more room for
activities so Soca tells the bean I want
you to see with more than just your eyes
yes this is the kind of thing Kanan
jarretts had to learn after he was
blinded by Maul at the end of season 2
of rebels how to seed with more than
just your eyes while Sabine is
blindfolded they do this awesome camera
editing trick do you know where I am
next to who Yang are you sure
very funny I love it we don't see Ahsoka
walk to sabine's right side and the
sound mix edits Rosario Dawson's voice
to be closer and on the right side of
the stereo makes it first but then
shifts to be on the left side of the
stereo mix when she suddenly appears on
the left side of frame we experience the
same subjective confusion that Sabine
does the camera stays on Sabine alone in
frame for a few seconds then
yes since Sabine cannot see where Ahsoka
is neither can we Sabine swings then
more air than the lightsaber kid but
there is one moment she makes progress
yeah
yeah she actually did use a bit of the
force there to sense The Bakken behind
her but then she just gets too greedy
with a kill lunge for getting her foot
into Ahsoka can trip her so it's not
sabine's lack of force sensitivity
though she is definitely number to the
force than the Jedi are it's really
sabine's impatience Ahsoka says anger
and frustration are quick to give power
but they also unbalance you yeah Ahsoka
means that literally Emmett borkly as
fear is the path to the dark side you
know it leads to anger hate separate Etc
but the force is really the balance
between them on to the new Republic
Fleet we see four blue painted a-wings
flying in formation past home one that
is Admiral akbar's mon calamari Flagship
from Return of the Jedi we see some cr90
Corvettes those are the ones with the 11
engines like the Tanta 4 had and a
hammerhead Corvette we saw these in
Rogue one the planet they orbit has a
vast cityscape surface could be
Coruscant but currently the new
Republic's capital is chandrilla that's
mon mothma's Homeworld the capital
currently rotates among the core worlds
in the future it's going to be hosnian
prime that's the system that gets
destroyed by Starkiller base and the
force awakens gendrella has more green
land and oceans it's not completely an
urban City skate so I'm assuming it's
either Coruscant or hosnian Pride
probably corsan Hera checks in with
first officer Vic Hawkins she's waiting
there are several Senators with her
one of them is ziono not leono Senator
Hamato ziono is I think the first major
detail to be pulled in live action from
the Star Wars resistance animated series
he's the father to kazuda ziono pilot of
the resistance they hail from hosnian
Prime and papa Zino stubbornly refuses
to accept kazuda joining the resistance
considering them extremists boo inside
this room which again seems to be the
auditorium style room that we saw
Monmouth but give everyone the briefing
about the both ends in Return of the
Jedi here are greets Chancellor
manmathma Genevieve O'Reilly returning
from Andor now elected the first
Chancellor after the fall of the Empire
with her as Senator ziono Senator
Rodrigo Senator marwood and a sender of
the grand race now there was a grand
Senator named ask who was a Palpatine
loyalist during the prequel era but nah
I don't think he'd be in the new
republic government this high up but who
knows apparently a loyalty oath with
your fingers crossed behind your back is
enough to get the top job with space
Nazi destroyers unsupervised manmathma
asks you look well how's young Jason
fine Chancellor in fact he's on board
Island
somewhere
causing trouble with chopper no doubt
yes there are very two jasons and Doula
Hera's son with Kanan Charis revealed in
the final minutes of the rebels finale
episode he's played in this episode by
Evan Whitten Dave filonia said that
Jason's name j-a-c-e-n is a tribute to
the Legends character Jason solo the son
of Han and Leia who eventually becomes
the Sith Lord darthadius yeah don't name
your kid Jason Senator Rodrigo says the
Imperial loyalists on corellia are
outliers since X amps had to take these
Odes of loyalty and it's kind of hard to
see here if she's just naive or actively
Pro Empire but with Rodrigo and ziono
and that Shifty looking Grand Senator
like notice how he nods when ziono shuts
down Hera's task force request that
would be either three to two or four to
one on any vote they had about this take
it away Kent I've said it before and
I'll say it again democracy simply
doesn't work Hera alludes to thrawn's
allies working on a way to find him in
addition to morgue announcement we know
of the Shadow Council in the Mandalorian
season 3 including Captain Pelion that
was thrawn's right-hand man in the
Timothy Zahn novels and currently played
by his Xander Berkeley in live action
saw him in the Mandalorian chapter 23.
mothma remembers thrawn for how
effective he was against Hera's Phoenix
Squadron over La fall in the final
season of rebels which led to Hera
crashing the next swing on lothal
getting captured tortured and kanan's
death while rescuing her Hera calls out
ziono though were you ever in the war
senator
no just sat back and waited to see you
came out on top damn so Hera currently
represents the views of Senator Leia
Organa whom Claudia Gray's bloodline
novel explores during these years as a
republic leader ousted by New Republic
political corruption and leaves to form
the resistance Hera's Defiance to ziono
here may later make azuda joining the
resistance field personal now real quick
we want to say thanks to Spin Master for
sponsoring this video as well as
introduce their new brand 4D build
featuring licensed 3D Star Wars puzzles
4D build makes detailed cardstock 3D
Puzzle model kits If You're a Star Wars
Superman who digs puzzles or wants to
add your Museum of Star Wars
collectibles you will love these
everything you need to build a 3D Puzzle
comes in the Box you're not gonna have
to go hunt down a tiny screwdriver or
anything like that each box contains a
set of cardstock puzzle sheets
instructions and a bottle of glue just
in case the instructions are super clear
and easy to follow and in about two to
three hours you can have a finished R2
unit now bigger puzzles take longer but
you know what they say the Death Star
wasn't built in a day destroyed in one
sure but not built there's so much
attention to detail and the puzzles are
super sturdy when they're done they are
designed with replica level detail and
made for showing off which is why every
model comes with a display stand to get
a 4D build Star Wars puzzle model kit of
your own just click the link in the
description below or head to target.com
for as little as 15 you can start your
own Star Wars puzzle collection today
Hera warns thrawn is not your typical
Imperial officer I know because I fought
against him he killed friends people who
were like family to me now it is worth
noting that thrawn doesn't really kill
many major characters in Rebels like
Kanan died because Governor price
blasted the Fuel Depot a decision that
thrawn actually hated because it slowed
down the production of his Thai
Defenders but his decisions absolutely
killed a lot of people many Phoenix
Squadron Pilots Rebel Fighters innocent
lothal residents he shot bendu just
kidding bendu didn't die he faded away
laughing so we're learning here how
attached Hera was to all these victims
Jason asks is it true and speed is going
to be a Jedi now where did you hear that
Chopper told me
up oh I love Chopper's utterances
and I don't know if this was a growl or
an awkward uh but remember Chopper was
the one Ezra handed his lightsaber off
to he's the one who tossed Sabine that
lightsaber in the rebels finale episode
he wants this transition to happen and
also hair Chopper's not the best
babysitter he's gonna teach Jason how to
be a war criminal now Jason of course
then asks I want to be a Jedi yeah I
know you do Chase yeah she is looking in
his eyes and totally seeing Kane and
Jairus and likely doesn't want Jason to
follow down that path because you know
it leads people to like hop on top of
fuel cells and hold back Flames to save
the people that you love
but also watch that Rebel season 4
breakdown because there is some
unresolved history with Caleb Doom when
he was brought to lothal it looks like
based off of those cave paintings by
Yoda Chiari Mundi and Mace Windu and
Jason it's totally inheriting that what
okay so back on the T6 Sabine says I was
hoping that the urgency of our situation
could
expedite my training a bit Jedi like
Anakin and Ahsoka were in a hurry to get
better with the ports during the Clone
Wars and for Anakin to go back and save
his mom which really is the worst time
to hone this kind of training because
you take it harder when you don't pick
it up fast enough you're worried that
every failure and setback is causing
pain and hurt somewhere around the
Galaxy peacetime is the best time to
become a good Jedi Sabine says that she
can't use the force and Ahsoka counters
Force resides in all living things even
you yes in Rebels trial of the dark
saber Kanan says essentially the same
thing about Sabine to Hera the force
resides in all living things but you
have to be open to it Sabine is blocked
her mind is conflicted she's so
expressive and yet so tightly wound
she's so Mandalorian which is a much
nicer way of putting it than what huyang
has been dropping this episode beep beep
uh you you suck Yang even continues to
talk the Jedi Order would not have
accepted her she is not an acceptable
candidate
by their standards standards which were
proven over a millennia
and failed ooh shots fired from Ahsoka
Ahsoka is expressing her parting ways
with the Jedi Order during Clone Wars
season 5 and yes the Jedi orders obvious
failure when Anakin betrayed them and
led the purge Ahsoka may also be stung
all the way back from the Clone Wars
movie when Anakin told her when they
first met you never would have made it
as Obi-Wan's Padawan but you might make
it as mine who Yang says you realize
historically there have been very few
mandalorians who ever became a Jedi well
one who did was named tar Vizsla the
first wielder of the darksaber and since
Sabine hails from house Vizsla
technically she is his descendant like
maybe she's like one 64th tar who Yang
also says
suppose you do come from a long line of
non-traditional Jedi yeah he's referring
to the chain of Masters that Ahsoka
comes from her master was Anakin his
master was Obi-Wan Kenobi his master was
Qui-Gon Jinn his master was Dooku and
his master was Yoda so all of them
exceptions to the norm Sabine does that
think that we have all tried to do
before when you're eating breakfast
alone and you try to force some in a cup
across the table and I love how she
initially Squints with one eye aiming
like a blaster her background of course
is in Weaponry but she exhales and she
refocuses keeping both eyes open to the
living Force we learn all the comms and
the denom system are being jammed
cutting off Hera's bad news and huyang
drops him out of hyperspace far from
citas following standard Jedi Mission
protocol which was referenced back in
Ashok episode one huyang says the
transport was in Orbit on the far side
of the planet however there also seems
to be a second object something much
larger yeah we get an ominous look at
the planet of sea toss and we can't help
but recall the Falcon crew arriving to
the Alderaan debris field and seeing a
moon that ended up being star that's no
moon
it's a space station six Pilots Led by
shin and morocc pursue them in these
awesome looking Fighters with weathered
red and yellow pink and a buzzing World
War II style design they somehow beat up
they look I'm gonna assume that these
ships come from the Clone Wars era maybe
modified bellulab 22s originally from
the Republic Commando game and later
came back in Revenge of the Sith and
Clone Wars as separatist Fighters the
hole on the nose though reminds me of
the mig-15 which was a Soviet design
fighter jet used in the Korean War it's
also kind of reminiscent of the P-47
Mustang with the rounded cowlings and
the nose of the f2f Brewster Buffalo
whatever it just looks old and Scrappy
it sounds awesome the rapid rate of
blaster fire is sick a lot of fun
watching these even if ahsoka's T6
should have been obliterated several
times just the dog fighting here is
great because George Lucas originally
based his aerial combat imagery for the
first Star Wars film on actual World War
II Air Battle footage so it's always
been part of the franchise's DNA Sabine
complains I see you got rid of my
presets
I never needed them yeah Ahsoka claims
to not need computers to aim because she
can use the force kind of sounds like
these two gotten a lot of in their
time after the rebels finale we need
some flashbacks to that so after Ahsoka
tried to train Sabine to learn to
anticipate and before rejecting urgency
as a way to improve one's skills now
Ahsoka gives in and she adapts Sabine
tell me what you need this teamwork
between the pilot and the Gunner is just
what makes this all so fun Herra and
Chopper did it in that cool move in
episode two Rey and Finn did it with the
Falcon and the force awakens and hey we
do it every time we ride Smugglers Run
hey you can keep pilot and Gunner I like
the engineer I like pushing the buttons
when they light up Ahsoka uses the
unique function of the T6 it's rotating
Wings to surprise the two pilots with a
game of chicken going vertical at the
last second catching them off guard so
Sabine can take one of them out and give
herself some confidence
her exaltation May remind you of Luke's
I got one from a new hope I got it
[Music]
but whereas Han Solo responded to him
with nice work kid but don't get cocky
Ahsoka just gets to being a very
wholesome good work it forgives her when
she misses one now from the eye of Scion
Morgan Ellsworth fires turbo lasers who
Yang says see if you can get a little
closer
please I don't know if it's just me but
David Tennant's tone here as who Yang
totally reminds me of Hannibal lecter's
line to Clarisse in Silence of the Lambs
closer please closer like Sabine pushing
it with that explosive HK Droid head in
episode 2 who Yang pushes it here just a
moment
scan complete
now Shin radios to Morgan
congratulations you almost got them
like the high-res dark sister Hollow
projections on the eye of Scion at the
end of episode 2. now even the audio
communication has a smoother Fidelity
like the Hardware Morgan is using on the
ship might have been designed
transmitted to her from thrawn's new
Galaxy or his old Galaxy I'm reminded of
the alien technology transmitted to
Earth in the movie contact which were
blueprints for creating a ring-based
transportation device to take us through
a wormhole back to them the tech that
thrawn and his forces use could be based
on some long forgotten but Superior
technology of the rakatan builders or
the celestial gods of mortis or whoever
it's going to end up being also I gotta
point this out the shots of shinhati in
her cockpit she wears the comms
headpiece so that the band goes under
her bangs she will not mess up her do
for this and yes it's the same kind of
headset that Anakin wears in the Battle
of Coruscant during this fun moment this
is where the fun begins meanwhile the
headset that Sabine wears looks like the
wiry one that Han Solo wears when he was
in the Falcon Gunner seat in a New Hope
now craziest moment of this episode
Ahsoka suits up in this fly spacesuit
Custom Design headgear that perfectly
fits her like who and yes I do not
understand the gravity if we're walking
out on the wing like that or when she
leaps why in the jump would form an arc
and not kick her out directly off in his
face according to Newton's third law but
you know what there is no Newton in Star
Wars folks there shouldn't even be sound
in space none of this is ever adhere to
the laws of physics but there might be
like magnetic Clips in her boots now on
her second flip jump Ahsoka uses her
lightsaber to sever the Fighter's Wing
reminding us of Rey's big flip move in
the rise of Skywalker on pasano when she
used her lightsaber to wreck kylo Ren's
TIE Interceptor now this just causes
Ahsoka to float loose but if you look
closely some sparks fly off of her back
tech so this may have been some kind of
Jetpack Thruster maybe a localized
gravity regulator I don't know I'm doing
my best here folks Sabine ends up using
the same rotating Wing mechanism that
ahsoki used before now to rake Ahsoka
back into the hatch now again balance
saw some pergol in the Cloudy Skies over
sea toss last episode and now Sabine and
Ahsoka see him up close
oh
foreign
[Music]
they look so good the closed captions on
Disney plus actually describe this sound
as melodic rumbling it is a huge deal
for Sabine to see these the Pergo were
of course the hyperspace whales that
Ezra summoned in the final episode of
rebels to defeat thrawn fulfilling
bendu's prophecy to thrawn in the season
3 finale that thrawn would be defeated
with many arms surrounding him in a cold
Embrace and those whales zipped both of
them off into hyperspace the Pergo were
first introduced in Rebel Season 2
Episode 15 the call when the ghost crew
came across an asteroid gas Refinery
where pergol feed on that gas to survive
Ezra made a connection with the alpha
Pergo by looking into its eye forming
this lifelong connection that he would
call upon in his hour of need in the
series finale I wonder if the clouds of
cetas might be composed of a similar
gaseous substance as what was in that
planetoid structure in the call episode
now in the rebels finale episode and we
see in this series Sabine has actually
added a pergol to the pauldron of her
armor so she has been dreaming of this
moment per girl do actually show up in
the constellations of the closing
credits along with a single both Wolf by
the planet lothal I actually translated
every single Rune planet and hidden clue
on that star map in another video
definitely watch it it's extremely
important to know what the series is
really doing and with Dave filoni so
obsessed with wolf imagery the character
name of maroc is based on the Arthurian
Legend a character associated with
Wolves feloni's X-Wing pilot characters
named Trapper wolf everything about the
Loth wolves that you can learn by
watching the rebels 4 recap video it's
just worth reminding everyone that
wolves and whales share a common
evolutionary ancestry as the reason
whales are mammals and not fish is that
they had a common momoland ancestor that
lives close to water and eventually
evolved into a whale now while in the
rebels finale there was a mix of big
pergol and smaller ones here there only
seem to be big ones have they grown
Sabine Pilots right by the big burgle's
eye so it is also important in this
moment that Sabine is piloting not
Ahsoka it's the beans time to fly I
haven't seen those creatures since the
day Ezra disappeared and I wonder if win
this huge Pergo looks into this cockpit
it might see it might zero in on the
friend who desperately misses the boy
that they flew off with the Pergo
actually helps them during this Chase
it's Angel lady tentacles fold down
behind the T6 closing it off from view
from shin and when Sabine finds an
opening it might have been one
intentionally created by the Pergo
moving its tentacles out of the way they
end up parking the T6 in this Grove of
red trees masking it as these red leaves
match the t6's red paint this setting
reminds me of the Mystic weirwood trees
in A Song of Ice and Fire just a lot of
interesting stuff going on here visually
actually its name citas like Arcana
clearly referencing the word Arcane
sitas must mean something as either the
seat of power or maybe these ruins are
kind of tossing themselves into the sea
while these Stonehenge inspired ruins
are positioned by the Sea it's just
interesting to me that the true open
Gulf that this point jumps out into is
up into the clouds with the whales and
beyond that into the Stars huiang
identifies the eye of Scion as a
hyperspace ring smaller versions of
these were used by Jedi starfighters
like the one Obi-Wan piloted and attack
of the Clones to dock up with and then
let the ring carry the hyperdrive this
one has seven engines so that it can
jump galaxies I like how the final shot
of Sabine and Ahsoka frames them on
either side of this ring both of them
equally propulsive to move this Union
forward but huyang has an interesting
line here the Jedi archives speak of
Intergalactic hyperspace Lanes between
galaxies which used to follow the
migration plots of star whales named
Pearl Jedi archives the Jedi knew about
other galaxies and they knew about the
pergol as the link to them in Rebel
season 4 episode 12 we meet a character
named Minister Hayden outside the lothal
Jedi Temple right before the world
Between Worlds episode and he discusses
Jedi lore with the emperor the symbols
and iconography a reminiscent of a
report I discovered in the Jedi archives
the mortise Gods the mortise gods in
Jedi archives so if these mortis gods
are Star Wars celestials if they come
from another galaxy and if the Jedi
archives knew about that this could all
be connected through the mortise gods
and the world Between Worlds a dimension
that transcends time look folks most of
the trailer footage has been seen now
all that's really left that we have not
seen an episode are the duel between
Ahsoka and Balin and this star map ruins
on cetas and a duel between Shin and
Sabine in the nearby trees that's
probably coming next episode since this
episode ends with balance sending his
forces into that Forest trailers have
also given us two shots of thrawn one
from behind one from in front so think
about that episodes 5 through 8 could
look like anything Dave filoni is
directing episode five so I think after
Ahsoka and balen's duel next episode the
wolves are gonna howl the best way to
support this channel is by grabbing and
Ahsoka inspired fulcrum shirts available
at nerd riot.shop please subscribe to
the break room for episodes of WikiLeaks
are as Soca after show and please
subscribe to all three channels on the
new rockstars Network I want to thank
Noah Shannon Jordan Morris for their
help writing and researching this
breakdown you can follow me on all
social platforms at eat a boss follow
new rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign